اعلن رئيس المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات
التركيه احمد ينار اجراء جوله ثانيه من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه بعد اظهار النتائج
الاوليه للانتخابات عدم حصول اي مرشح على
النسبه الكافيه للفوز ومن المقرر ان تجري
انتخابات لاعاده في 28 من الشهر الجاري
بين مرشحي الرئاسه الرئيس الحالي رجب طيبه
اردوغان ومرشح تحالف الشعب كما الكليتش
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه الخاصه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر اقدمها لكم مباشره من
اسطنبول ولنا في نقاش خبرها ثلاثه مسارات
ما هي ابرز الخلاصات التي يمكن استنتاجها
من النتائج الاوليه للانتخابات التركيه
والى اي حد عكست اوزان الاحزاب السياسيه
التركيه
الى اين يتجه المشهد السياسي التركي على
ضوء هذه النتائج وما هي تاثيراتها
المحتمله على مستقبل الخارطه الحزبيه في
البلاد
وما هي الارتدادات التي يمكن ان تحدث هذه
النتائج الاوليه للانتخابات التركيه على
علاقات انقره بمحيطها الاقليمي والدولي
[موسيقى]
بحسب رئيس المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات في
تركيا احمد ينار فان جوله الاعاده
للانتخابات الرئاسيه ستجرى في 28 من الشهر
الجاري بين الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان
ومنافسه كمال كليتش دار اوغلو بعد ان فشل
اي من المرشحين في الحصول على ما يزيد عن
50% من اصوات الناخبين النتائج الاوليه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه اظهرت بحسب
ينار قبل احصاء اخر خمسه وثلاثين الف صوت
ولن تكون كافيه على كل حال لتغيير نتيجه
الكليه للانتخابات اظهرت ان الرئيس
اردوغان حصل على
49.51 بالمئه من اصوات الناخبين بينما حصد
منافسه كمال كريتش دار اوغلو على
44.88% من الاصوات
[موسيقى]
نرحب بضيوفنا هنا في استوديو الجزيره
الخاص في اسطنبول لتغطيه الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والتشريعيه التركيه السيد الرسول
طوسون النائب السابق في البرلمان عن الحزب
العداله والتنميه والقيادي في الحزب
والسيده ايفر يسكان كوبال مسؤوله شؤون
المراه بحزب الشعب الجمهوري في اسطنبول
مرحبا بكما سيد رسول الطرفان لم يستطعا
الحسم من الجوله الاولى ماذا تقرا في هذا
التطور بالمشهد الانتخابي الرئاسي في
تركيا فاذا القائنا نتائج الانتخابات حسب
التحالفات نرى هناك تحالفين تحالف الجمهور
الذي يقوده اردوغان وتحالف الامه الذي
يقوده كمال كريستال فاذا ابقينا على
النتائج حسب التحالفات نرى ان تحالف
الجمهور قد فاز في انتخابات
البرلمان وحصل على اغلبيه المقاعد
321 فقط هذا فوز قد تم حزمه
من ناحيه انتخابات برلماني اما الانتقامات
الرئاسيه ايضا التحالف الجمهوري تقدم او
لنقل الرئيس اردوغان تقدم منافسه خمسه في
المئه من الاصفاد فلذلك نرى هناك نجاح فوز
بارز ولكنه لم يحسم من الجوله الاولى وهذه
نجاح بارز لتحالف الجمهور الا ان الرئاسه
لم
تحسم فبقيت
الانتخابات الى اعاده الى الجوله هو سؤال
كيف تقراون هذا التطور في المشهد
الانتخابي الرئاسي سيد طوسون هنا سؤال
يعني نقرا هكذا يعني نقرا هناك فوز
للتحالف الجمهوري وخساره للتحالف الامه
لانهم ايضا حزب الشباب الجمهوري كان له
ميه
سته واربعين مقعد في الانتخابات الماضيه
سنه
2018 والان حصل على
169 فقط لكن ثمانيه وثلاثين من المقاعد
للاحساب الاخرى هناك تراجع في مقاعد حزب
الشعب جمهوري ايضا يعني تراجع في اصوات
التحالف الامه وتقدم في اصوات تخالف
البارحه قالوا بان حزب العداله والتنميه
ايضا تراجع في البرلمان ولكن على كل حال
نحن في الرئاسه وخاصه في الجوله الثانيه
السيده كوبال ما رسائل الناخبين لكل طرف
نعم الرئيس اردوغان تقدم ولكنه لم يحسم
والمعارضه ستكون موجوده في الجوله الثانيه
ولكن ما زالت
متاخره على صعيد الاصوات ونسب التصويت ما
رسائل
الاتراك لكلا الطرفين
شكرا على الاستضافه من اجل تفسيري هذه
النتائج والنظري فيها عندما نتحدث عن
الانتخابات عاده من السهل جدا التحدث
والتركيز فقط على الارقام لكن حتى في ذلك
اذا مرقنا بالتركيز على الارقام فقط فان
حزبنا
وايضا الاحزاب الاخرى وما كسبناه في هذه
الانتخابات
هنالك انخفاض
في نتائج حزب العداله والتنميه وهنالك
تصاعد
تدريجي في الاحزاب المعارضه اذا ما قمنا
بتركيز فقط على النتائج الاوليه لان يعني
الامر كثير لكن هذا هذا امر الامر الثاني
عندما ننظر الى الام ريف من منظور من منظر
من منظوري السيد كمال كلك دار اوغلو فان
هذه هي الانتخابات لم تكن في مناخ عادل
متكافئ اذا ساقول ان
حلف تحالف
الشاب قد نجح بشكل كبير قد لا تعكس
الارقام هذه لكن على المدى الطويل سنرى
هنالك الكثير من النجاحات التي ستتحقق
لانه برغم كل شيء كان يجري في تركيا
السقف كان كان عاليا جدا قبيل الانتخابات
كان الحديث عن فوز في الرئاسه وايضا عن
تقدم في البرلمان وهذا كله لم يتحقق
للمعارضه المجتمعه في الطاوله السداسيه
ساعيد السؤال كان سقف الطاوله السداسيه
مرتفع جدا قبيل الانتخابات كان الحديث عن
حسم في الرئاسه وعن تقدم ايضا في البرلمان
لصالح المعارضه وهذا كله لم يتحقق
ما كان الطموح والحماسه عاليه وكان
الاشخاص ضمن التحالف كانوا يركزون على
الانتخابات الرئاسيه ربما كان هذا الامر
خاطئا اننا ركزنا كثيرا على الانتخابات
الرئاسيه ولم نركز بنفس الشيء على
الانتخابات
البرلمانيه لكن بالتاكيد كان الحافز
والكنه الروح والحماسه عاليه اعتقد انه في
الجوله الثانيه هذه هذه الروحيه ستستمر
لانه اذا راينا الى الفيديو السيد كمال
اوغلو لخمسه دقائق اعتقد كان كلامه حاسما
ومصمما قال اننا سنستمر بالنظالي وسنحقق
ما نطمح اليه
سنتحدث بعد قليل عن السيناريوهات الجوله
المقبله زودناك بمعطف لان الطقس بارد الان
في هذه الساعه في اسطنبول التصريحات عن
الرغبه بالتغيير قبيله الانتخابات كانت
سائده خاصه لدى فئه الشباب الان مع هذه
النتائج هل ثبتت
موازين القوى والقدره للاحزاب السياسيه في
تركيا سيد رسول الجمهور
وخاصه الرئيس اردوغان لم
يكافح او لم ينافس التحالف الامه لمحتها
بل كانت المنافسه بين اردوغان بين القوى
الامبرياليه العالميه فلذلك النتيجه هذه
تعتبر بعد 20 سنه من بقائه في الحكم تعتبر
هذه النتيجه نجاحا
لان لم يبقى هناك الا نصف في المياه من
الاصوات ليحسم النتائج بالنسبه
لمقوله او الدعوه التغيير اي نعم
الدعايه التي
ابدتها المعارضه
بكلمه التعيين تغيير لكن هذا التغيير لم
يحدث بل بالعكس البرلمان قد حصل تحالف
الجمهور اغلبيه البرلمان لم يحدث تغيير
فثانيا ماذا كان هدف
تحالف الامه هناك هدف واحد وهو تغيير
النظام رئاسه الى نظام من برلماني عندما
حصل تحالف الجمهور اغلبيه البرلمان هذا
الهدف قد زال لم يبقى لتحالف الامه هدفا
وليس له قدره في تغيير لا النظام ولا اي
شيء بالنسبه في
مجال التشريع السيده ايفر كانت تدون عندما
تحدثت عن الامبرياليه العالميه كان الرئيس
اردوغاني يواجه
الامبرياليه العالميه في في هذا في هذا
الاستحقاق باقتضاب لو سمحتي
السيد رسول قال بان الرئيس اردوغان في هذه
الانتخابات كان يواجه ما وصفها
بالامبرياليه العالميه وليس فقط التحالف
الطاوله السداسيه المعارض لديك تعليق على
هذه النقطه
الامر لا افهم السؤال بشكل واضح الامر
معقد قليلا بالنسبه لي ساتخطى هذا السؤال
ما نقلت المشهد السياسي في تركيا بعد
النتائج التي تكشفت سيده ايفر بالنسبه لكم
بعد الجوله الاولى ما الذي سنتوقعه اعتقد
ان ما بامكاننا ان نتوقعه هو منافسه محتد
اعتقد ان الحمل
الانتخابيه الان
يتم نسيانها في المرحله الاولى وستبدا
سيبدا المعسكران ربما بحمله جديده من
الصور والفيديوهات الجديده الامر المضحك
انه اي شيء ما تقوم به احزاب الطاوله
سته انه يكون هنالك احتماليه ان
ربما
تاخذه ياخذه حزب العداله والتنميه وتقوم
بتغيير هذه الفيديوهات وبضع صور غير صحيحه
تقوم باشياء لم يقوموا بها ويقول اشياء لم
يقولها بالتالي قد لا تكون هنالك منافسه
عادله اذا لم تكن هنالك منافسه عادله فان
النتائج من المحتمل ان تكون غير صحيحه
النتائج ستكون
قانونيه لكنها لن تكون اخلاقيه اذا لم يكن
هنالك مناخ منافسه صحيح مع ذلك واي شيء
سيحدث نحن هنا موجودون لاننا نمثل 50% اذا
ما نظرت الى اردوغان هو حقق 50% لكن هنالك
50% لا يختلفون معه لدينا الشباب والنساء
الذين هم ضد
توقعات اردوغان لانه اي تغيير قد يجريه
للنساء بالمواضح انه لم يكن لصالح النساء
بل كان فقط لاستعراضات مسرحيه ليقول انه
كان ناجحا في
نهجه اذا لم تستخدم النسوه حقوقهن ما
الفائده من ذلك ما اقوله ان الشعب ليس راض
عما حدث
سيد رسول ما التاثيرات المحتبله على
مستقبل التحالفات بعد النتائج التي تكشفت
في الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات
التحالفات في الحقيقه هناك تحالفا كبيران
تحالف الامه وتخالف الجمهوري
ضمن تحالف الجمهور والبحث الان عن اصوات
لسد هذه الثغره النصف بالمئه للوصول الى
دراسه انا لا اتوقع ان يكون هناك
تغيرات في داخل التحالف انما التحالفان
كلاهما
سعيان للحصول على الاصوات التي ذهبت الى
سنان اوغان هناك خمسه بالمئه من الاصوات
موجوده فهذه الاصوات هي التي
ستشكل مصير
الانتخابات في الجوله الثانيه فلذلك تحالف
الجمهور وكذلك تخالف الامه
يسعى كل
لاقناع السيد
اوغان
ولاقناع الذين صوتوا لصالح اوغان لان
هؤلاء الناخبون الذين صمتوا
انما هذه الاصوات كانت كيف سيتعامل
العداله مع التنميه والتنميه عفوا مع ما
يرفضه اصلا سنان اوغان وهو موضوع اللاجئين
هو يريد اعاده اللاجئين فورا الى بلدانهم
كيفستعمل
وبين حزب التنميه لان حزب العداله قد تم
يقول ايضا نحن سنرحل السوريين بشكل طواعي
طواعيه بعد ان فتحنا لهم مجالات في شمال
سوريا فالاخ هو ان يقول انا لا اريد
السوريين نرحلهم وهو يعرف جيدا وهو خبير
في هذا الشان انه لا يستطيع ان يرحل لان
هناك حقوق لهؤلاء اللاجئين فلذلك انا لا
ارى هناك يعني فارق كبير بين رؤيه
حزب التحالف عفوا رز بالاعداء والتنميه في
ترحيل
الناجحين اللاجئين هناك ليس لاجل سوري فقط
هناك لاجئين او فان ليبيين ومصريين
سيده ايفر ما مصير المعارضه التركيه امام
مصير الطاوله السداسيه بعد هذا الفشل في
التقدم بالانتخابات الرئاسيه وايضا الفشل
في الحصول على اصوات غالبه في مجلس النواب
كما كانت الوعود قبيل الانتخابات ما
التاثيرات على المعارضه في المستقبل
ساعيد طرح السؤال مره جديده هل تعتقدي بما
ان هناك سيكون تاثيرات للنتائج التي خرجت
وبعدم قدره المعارضه والطاوله السداسيه
على التقدم في الانتخابات الرئاسيه وايضا
على حصول على مزيد من المقاعد في البرلمان
مره اخرى انتم تركزون فقط على الارقام
بالنهايه
نعم الانتخابات والسياسه لا تتعلق
بالارقام فقط ربما نركز على امور اخرى في
هذه المعادله على الرغم من ان هذه الجوله
الاولى
لربما كانت لم تكن في المقدمه لكنني اعتقد
بامكانيه احراز نتائج افضل في الجوله
الثانيه وقد يكون هنالك سيد اوغانك يتحول
الى جانبنا او الى الجانب الاخر ما تزال
هنالك الكثير من علامات الاستفهام حول
موقفه
اعتقد ان السيد
ان يحقق النتائج اللازمه للانتخابات
الرئاسيه ايضا اعتقد انه يجب ان نركز على
هذا الامر ان الحمله الانتخابيه باكملها
ركزت على
اللاجئين
والمهاجرين وايضا
هذا امر مهم جدا في تركيا بالتالي ستكون
قضيه مهمه القضيه المشكله في هذا الامر ان
الامر لا يتعلق فقط
بترحيل اللاجئين لكن بمساله
عوده سوريا الى
حالها وان يكون لديهم امكانيه للعوده الى
سوريا بشكل امن لاننا لا نريد اي احد ان
يعاني اذا ما تمت استعاده سوريا
علينا ان نراهم ونلتقي بهم ونتحدث معهم
اذا اذا ما اردنا ان
نلبي مساله حقوق الانسان في سوريا يجب ان
تكون تركيا منخرطه في هذا الامر لكن
اردوغان قام
حاول ان يستخدم اللاجئين في
الحصول على الاموال من اوروبا وهذه ليست
سياسه صحيحه في رايي ربما
قد يكون هنالك مساله
ارسال اللاجئين بشكل امن
لان هذا الامر يمثل مشكله اجتماعيه الامر
ليس
يمثل مشكله اقتصاديه فقط لكنه مشكله
اجتماعيه
سيد رسول سؤال الاخير هل من تاثيرات لهذه
النتائج على السياسه الداخليه وخاصه
الخارجيه لحزب العداله والتنميه والرئيس
اردوغان في المستقبل
بالتاكيد هناك تاثيرات سنراها فيما بعد
خاصه بعد الجوله الثانيه التي
سيفوز فيه الرئيس اردوغان في السياسه
الداخليه لان في الداخل هناك قضايا يجب ان
تواجهها الحكومه على راسها الغلاء وعلى
راسها المنطقه المنكوبه وكذلك مكافحه
الارهاب
وكذلك هناك قضايا ايضا خارجيه
تتاثر من نتائج هذه الانتخابات لان
التركيه اذا عند فوز السيد اردوغان
اردوغان سياسته الخارجيه تبنى على المحور
التركي لا تب على المحور الغربي ولا على
المحور الامريكي ولا الروسي سياسه متوازنه
كما حصل في من الاخيره هو الذي كان قد
استطاع ان يبرم اتفاقيه
شكرا لك يا سيد رسول
النائب السابق في البرلمان عن حزب العداله
والتنميه والسيده ايفر باسكان كوبال
مسؤوله شؤون المراه بحزب الشعب الجمهوري
شكرا لكما بهذا تنتهي مشاهدينا هذه الحلقه
من برنامج من وراء الخبر من هنا من
اسطنبول شكرا لحسن المتابعه الى اللقاء
بامان الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]